si en 2010 vous passez vos vacances
d'été en chine vous auriez pu tomber sur
ça l'embouteillage le plus long de
l'histoire 100 km de voitures bloquées
pendant 11 jours c'est littéralement un
parking à son pic les gens n'avançait
que de 1 km par jour plus lent qu'un
escargot les habitants du coin malin
venaient vendre de la nourriture de
l'eau 15 fois leur prix normal vous
trouvez salon pourtant si vous conduisez
régulièrement à paris chaque année vous
passez 140 heures dans les bouchons
l'équivalent de 14 après midi ensoleillé
avec vos amis bloqué dans votre voiture
tout ça ça coûte cher à l'économie 20
milliards d'euros par an et vous savez
ce qu'est le plus fou c'est que c'est
facilement évitables la science est
exactement comment fonctionnent les
embouteillages et comment les régler
comment naissent les embouteillages
vous les connaissez ces longues heures
bloqués sur l'autoroute du soleil vous
vous dites qu'il y ait un accident que
les gens s'arrêtent pour regarder puis
sans aucune raison tout redevient fluide
pas de carcasses de voitures pas
d'engins de chantier vous êtes sorti des
bouchons sans explication vous venez de
traverser ce qu'on appelle un
embouteillage fantôme un phénomène tout
à fait normal qu'ils aient causé par
rien du tout leur existence a été
démontré en 2008 par youki sugiyama avec
cette expérience ils demandent à des
automobilistes de conduire en cercle
allure constante
l'objectif c'est de reproduire une route
un peu encombré mais pas trop au début
tout se passe bien c'est fluide mais si
quelqu'un ralenti c'est la réaction en
chaîne chaque voiture freine pour ne pas
rentrer dans la personne de devant en
quelques secondes un embouteillage
appareils pire il se propage en arrière
comme une onde de choc et
l'embouteillage peut devenir quasi
infini la cause notre temps de réaction
vous allez toujours ralentir plus fort
que la voiture de devant et démarré plus
lentement qu'elle plein de petits
détails qui s'accumulent de voiture en
voiture de façon un sympathique pour
tendre vers l'immense câble bouchons or
si toutes les voitures accéléré en même
temps l'embouteillage disparaîtrait un
problème qui s'ajoute cvo biais cognitif
il nous pousse à faire des choses bêtes
accélérer brutalement quand ça avance
donc freiner encore plus fort ou changer
de voie parce qu'on pense que là notre
avance et moins sur ce point la science
à des bunkers oui la fille d'à côté
avance quand tu es à l'arrêt c'est
frustrant mais ce que tu ne vois pas
c'est qu'elle même est à l'arrêt quand
tu avances pendant une longue attente
ton cerveau est beaucoup plus attentif
le temps passe plus lentement mais in
fine et les deux arriveront en même
temps c'est pour ça que le code de la
route interdit de changer de voie dans
les bouchons ça ne fait que les
amplifier cette impatience peut
néanmoins parfois être bénéfique prenez
une voix boucher à cause de travaux vous
voyez le panneau bout la route est
coupée ça vous oblige à vous rabattre
sur le côté par civisme vous le faites
le plus tôt possible pour pas être le
mec relou qui pensent pouvoir doubler
tout le monde se mettre tout bout et
forcé son entrée à la dernière minute
pourtant c'est lui qui a raison on vous
rabattre entre auto vous utilisez pas
tout la route disponible donc vous
augmenter la densité de voitures sur la
voie mais en plus comme tout le monde ne
sera pas au même moment ça empêche le
flux de voitures de s'écouler à un
rythme régulier le plus optimal c'est
d'aller au bout puis de passer chacun
son tour on appelle ça la méthode de la
fermeture éclair et cite une obligation
dans le code de la route allemands et
belges depuis 2014 cette méthode permet
de réduire de 40% la longueur d'un
bouchon vous commencez à comprendre la
principale cause des embouteillages
c'est vous en ile de france seuls 13%
des bouchons sont causés par des travaux
des accidents tout le reste serait
évitable par plus de pédagogie auprès
des conducteurs les fourmis qui elles
n'ont pas ces problèmes d'individualisme
de frustration qui savent rester ordonné
n'ont pas ces problèmes d'embouteillages
elles peuvent communiquer collectivement
via des routes de phéromones qui
fluidifie énormément le trafic chez
l'homme c'est plus compliqué mais vous
avez quand même votre rôle à jouer des
expériences psychologiques ont montré
qu'une voiture qui conduit parfaitement
en influence positivement 20 autres il
suffirait que 5 % des voitures ne fasse
aucune erreur et les embouteillages
diminuerait drastiquement ce chiffre de
5% il a un vrai sens en statistiques
c'est un nombreux critiques quand il
s'agit des mouvements de foule aux usa
au début du coc vide il a suffi que 5 %
des gens décident de dévaliser les
rayons papier toilette pour que tout le
monde se met à en acheter un peu plus
résultat rupture nationale alors que
tout le monde aurait pu en avoir les
meilleures solutions restent donc
technique est structurelle et avant de
vous les expliquer donc je vous invite à
devenir de bons conducteurs
qui connaissait bien votre code de la
route avec le partenaire de cette vidéo
wyss be drive oui si vous connaissez
c'est la trousse à outil ultime des
jeunes ils ont percé avec leurs sites
qui vous trouvent toutes les aides
sociales auxquelles vous avez droit mais
vous accompagne aussi ailleurs assure
santé offre d'emploi et le permis de
conduire le comme normalement c'est cher
tu révises sur décide pas beau ou dans
des gros bouquin austère avec wyss be
drive tout le contraire ça donne envie
d'étudier déjà ça coûte pas grand chose
14 euros 90 en une fois avec notre code
de réduction trash 10 euros de reduc et
c'est illimité pendant un an si tu es
pressé tu as aussi une formule de
semaine encore moins cher et tu as tous
les fiches de révisions les examens
blancs chronométrés les 2200 question
officiels qui sont posées tu vas arriver
à l'examen tu sauras déjà tout et tu vas
faire 40 sur 40 cerise sur le gâteau ou
usb drive peut accompagner pour
l'inscription au code il gère tout perso
en ce moment j'ai pour projet de passer
enfin mon permis et je vais clairement
utilisé wyss be drive dans cette
situation que fais-tu des maires de toi
maintenant mdr on s'est mis ensemble
allez sur le lien en descriptions merci
vous dit comment résoudre le problème
des embouteillages moi c'est un problème
de place y'a qu'à agrandir les routes
mettons des autoroutes au milieu de
paris ça réglerait le problème ok
responsa la cathy freeway était la
seconde autoroute la plus branchée des
états unis chaque année 25 millions
d'eur était perdu dans les bouchons
alors en 2008 l'état investit près de 3
milliards de dollars pour en faire
l'autoroute la plus large du monde 26
voix résultat ça n'a fait qu'empirer les
choses entre 2011 et 2014 le temps de
trajet augmenté de 55% comment c'est
possible plus de voir ça veut dire plus
de place pour les voitures non en fait
c'est à cause du paradoxe de bresse tout
le monde veut prendre le chemin qui fait
gagner du temps quand on a grandi une
route le nombre de gens qui l'empruntent
augmente proportionnellement toutes les
personnes qui prenaient un autre chemin
veulent maintenant prendre le nouveau
bien plus rapide soit disant c'est un
paradoxe que doit résoudre tous les
jours l'application waze quand il y à
des bouchons ne te conseille notre voie
plus rapide un raccourci c'était vrai
pour les premiers mais vu que tout le
monde finissait par appliquer le conseil
vous devinez la suite des quartiers
résidentiels pas du tout vu pour la
route complètement saturé ça oblige les
mairies à intervenir comme à toulouse où
les rues résidentielles ont été rendus d
agréables à conduire limitée à 30 km
heure juste pour faire fuir les adeptes
de wade et c'est justement une première
piste efficace réduire la vitesse
maximale dynamiquement une route remplis
de voitures ça ressemble beaucoup à un
tuyau rempli d'eau versée tout d'un coup
n'accédera pas le débit au contraire
l'eau s'accumulera à l'entrée la
solution c'est de verser lentement les
faits faster in the lower ça fonctionne
même avec des humains qui essaie de
sortir d'un bâtiment à faible allure les
embouteillages sont en effet pas le
temps de se former on a testé ça sur
l'autoroute a20 aux pays bas quand la
densité de voitures augmenter la vitesse
passer automatiquement de 100 à 80
km/heure résultat d'un pour cent du
temps en moins dans les bouchons
deuxième piste réduire le nombre de
voitures là où elles ne sont pas utiles
non la famille du 15e arrondissement qui
fait cinq minutes de voiture pour aller
conduire églantine à l'école ça n'est
pas nécessaire pour empêcher ce
comportement les villes ont eu l'idée de
taper au portefeuille c'est ce qu'a fait
singapour en 1975 en imposant une taxe
sur toutes les voitures qui roulent en
ville succès immédiat
76 % de véhicules en moins aujourd'hui
presque cinquante ans après seuls 15%
des habitants de singapour ont une
voiture et c'est pourtant l'un des pays
avec le pib par habitant le plus élevé
sont pas les seuls londres l'a adopté
stockholm aussi et c'est une réussite
pour l'économie de la ville c'est pas un
truc de bobos écolos mais de la pure
science on critique la ville de paris
soit disant anti voiture mais en réalité
à l'échelle des pays riches on est très
conservateur dites vous qu à paris 30 %
des voitures en circulation ce sont des
gens qui cherchent de la place pour se
garer et la bonne solution c'est
paradoxalement pas de rajouter des
parkings qui ferait qu encore plus de
gens prendraient la voiture non il faut
rendre ce moyen de transport moins
viable pour les gens qui n'ont pas
vraiment besoin ou qui ont de meilleures
alternatives
s'ils arrêtent les artisans et les gens
qui habitent loin auront plus de place
l'autre solution c'est l'intelligence
artificielle avec une application comme
macarons qui vous donne les chemins de
recherche optimale pour trouver une
place qui actuellement en déploiement à
la défense et à courbevoie troisième
piste changeait les infrastructures
routières les croisements
perpendiculaire
surtout ceux à l'américaine sont une
catastrophe urbanistique 50 % des
accidents mortels s'y produisent c'est
juste invivable pour les piétons comme
les voitures qui doivent attendre de
longues minutes dans les bouchons
logique vous rouler très vite puis
freiné très fort pour s'arrêter au feu
rouge on peut faire autrement c'est ce
qu'a montré l'impressionnant chantier de
la kansas expressway 44 aux états unis
on est passé d'une intersection
terrifiante avec un accident à des
bouchons de 25 minutes à une merveille
de l'ingénierie le diffuseur en losange
regardez comment c'est fluide ça marche
tellement que le magazine popular
science l'a élue meilleure innovation
technique de 2009 pourtant ça n'est
jamais aussi efficace et sécurisant
qu'un bon vieux rond point non seulement
c'est les français qui l'ont inventé
mais on est les champions du monde avec
très 260000 carrefour giratoire aux
états unis sachez le et la population
est contre les ronds-points persuadé
qu'on y tourner des heures sans pouvoir
en sortir une sorte de manège infernal
en c'est en france que c'est une idée
reçue et les rares vu les états unienne
qui l'ont testé ont observé une baisse
de 90% des accidents fatals - 40 %
d'accidents impliquant les piétons et
surtout c'est très efficace pour
désengorger les embouteillages puisqu'on
ne freine pas au ralenti avec une
densité de voitures forcément limité on
pourrait en mettre absolument partout ce
que des jantes est dans des jeux vidéo
et ça a l'air de fonctionner c'est juste
que dans la réalité ça coûte cher c'est
long à construire et il faut de la place
qui plus est ça marche moins bien sur
des routes très encombrées quand il ya
beaucoup de véhicules larges comme des
camions ou quand une voix domine toutes
les autres en terme de trafic ça empêche
les voies secondaires de saint céré on
préféra alors un diffuseur en diamant
avec le rouge et justement quatrième
piste des feux rouges intelligent dans
un monde idéal il n'y en aurait pas et
puisque vous ne respectez pas la
priorité à droite pas plus que 7 des
piétons et que si on vous ralentit pas
régulièrement vous avez tendance à
dépasser les limites de vitesse on est
obligé d'en mettre vous le savez
peut-être pas mais beaucoup de feux
rouges ne sont pas gérées sur un
minuteur fixe des humains et ordinateurs
interviennent continuellement à paris
par exemple c'est géré par le pc du test
si les capteurs au sol détecte une
anomalie dans le trafic la cadence des
feux rouges sera modifiée en conséquence
c'est pour ça que pendant la nuit vous
êtes peut être déjà arrivé de rouler en
ligne droite avec des feux qui passe
petit à petit au vert comme s'ils vous
anticipez tellement satisfaisant sorte
eh bien ce n'est pas de la chance mais
le calcul d'un ordinateur on appelle ça
une onde verte maintenant c'est pas le
cas dans toutes les villes et si vous
ratez dans le canon sage des feux rouges
ça peut produire des véritables
catastrophes délisle complètement bouché
parce que comme vous le voyez chaque
intersection fini par accumuler trop de
voitures pour dégorger la précédente
imaginez les calculs mathématiques
inferno que ça doit être pour gérer ça à
l'échelle d'une ville entière cinquième
piste la voiture autonome ça serait la
vraie révolution la fin des bouchons
elles pourront tout calculé à la
perfection et se synchroniser en évitant
les erreurs humaines ça serait super
mais ça va mettre du temps car il suffit
qu'une personne humaine conduisent au
milieu de voitures autonomes et il
pourra provoqué un bouchon avec des
effets de chaîne même nos enfants ne
connaîtront pas un monde sans bouchon en
attendant on ne peut que vous suggérez
de devenir de bons conducteurs en
connaissant votre code de la route avec
l'application wii speak drive vous a
parlé le lien est dans la description
pensez à vous abonner si ce genre de
vidéos vous plaisent à l'est les amis
ciao
[Musique]